hello everyone and yes it is that time
of year the time of year for a year-end
list and you know for me that year- end
list comes at the beginning of 2024 I
definitely didn't make as many reviews
or as many videos this past year but I
certainly listened to a lot of music and
I watched some great movies and yeah I
just want to go through and talk about
my favorite stuff over the last year so
for this past year I'm going to have a
top 20 list of albums and then 15
honorable mentions and then after that
I'll go through top 10 movies and then
maybe just a handful of TV shows but
anyway let's get started with the music
let me start with just a run through of
my 15 honorable mentions these are just
going to be an alphabetical order we've
got ESOP rocks integrated Tech Solutions
amalu with I came home late Blockheads
the ox from zarf Z artificial
intelligence we've got Drake scary hours
3 he buildt it that way but then it was
just these six Deluxe Tracks but I do
think they deserve recognition on their
own from snack we've got naaw Jim Dugen
from Mandy Indiana I've seen a way sk's
new album the land is inhospitable and
so are we from Paris Texas midair Teo
touchdowns how do you sleep at night
Travis Scotts Utopia wiely from Atlanta
with killing time before the flood Young
Fathers heavy heavy young nudies gumbo
and last would be Zack Bryan with the
self-titled album and with this slightly
different camera angle it is time to get
into my top 20 albums of the year of
course unlike the honorable mentions
these will be ranked so let's get
started at number 20 I've got Daniel
Caesar's Never
[Music]
Enough my fiance is a huge fan of Daniel
Caesar and it's fair to say that I've
gotten more into his music because of
her and she's been listening to this
album pretty much non-stop this year and
honestly I don't blame her I don't like
it as much obviously it's coming in at
number 20 but there's nothing too crazy
about the album but it's just a
collection of great songs and I don't
know what more I could ask from somebody
like him coming in at number 19 is
Westside guns and then you pray for
me
this is basically the spiritual sequel
to pray for Paris and I feel like this
one wasn't quite as well received
obviously because weside gun went for
kind of a trap sound on a lot of these
songs but I feel like he does pretty
well on a lot of them there are a couple
that I don't think quite hit the mark
but the majority of the album is really
solid I I have a great time with this
one coming in at number 18 we've got new
blue Sun from Andre
3000 this of course is the an album that
Andre 3000 decided to drop this year I
feel like that is the appropriate term
for it it's not just flute music but
yeah this one is a great peaceful listen
from front to back if you haven't
listened to it I'd highly recommend it
while you're doing other things whether
that's studying or working or whatever
it's just it's great music to soothe the
soul in the background at number 17 I
have M DeMarco one Wayne
[Music]
G this album is not exactly an album
it's more of a compilation of years
worth of demos I was going to say this
album is 4 hours long but it's actually
9 hours that 4 hours is just the tracks
that I ended up enjoying and wanting to
keep in a playlist but yeah this is a
really cool sort of historical log of
music that M Dem Marco made it's mostly
instrumental and some of the songs are
really impressive you know he gets into
different ambient stuff here and there
too it's pretty cool at number 16 I have
back to Moon Beach from Kurt
vial if you've watched my channel for a
little while you'd probably know that
I'm a fan of Kurt vile and this is
another good alum album from him it
feels like he's veering almost into
country music a little bit with this one
and there's even a cover of a Christmas
song Must Be Santa so that's kind of
cool but yeah as usual you know very
reflective meditative stuff from him at
number 15 I have wer from Earl
Sweatshirt and The Alchemist
Iain as I said in my review of this one
this is a perfect pairing that I feel
like we've been waiting for for a long
time they just have very congruent
Styles production front to back is
excellent Earl Sweatshirt is as usual in
great form rapping on it it's it's just
a really good project to listen to at
number 14 I have laigh from
[Music]
SAA I know it's been a long time since
SAA dropped an album and people were
definitely anticipating this one and I
would be shocked if this didn't at least
meet people's expectations if not exceed
it lot of exploratory stuff on here and
for the most part you know it's like
he's exploring his own mind as identity
and yeah I don't know that's just kind
of how SAA is you know it's it's very
contemplative music but a lot of songw
writing and song structures is really
interesting and engaging and yeah this
is a very very solid album at number 13
I have maps from Billy Woods and Kenny
seagull I feel like to not include some
kind of Billy Woods mention whether on
an album list or a song list this year
you're kind of doing yourself a
disservice cuz he's been all over the
place this year and of all the stuff
that I've heard from him this year Maps
has definitely left the most impression
Billy sounds great and right at home on
the dark and gritty production as usual
and yeah this is a this is a fantastic
album it's definitely one of the best
rap albums of the year at number 12 I've
got Javelin from sufan
[Music]
Stevens It's I've been a big fan of
sufan for a long time and it feels great
to have a solo project from him make my
list he's in classic sufan form on this
one you know very vulnerable the
production kind of dips into a lot of
his work in the past some parts of it
sound like age of ads some of it sounds
like Illinois it's really really good
one if you're a fan of sufan I'm sure
you've already heard it if you're not
you should definitely check this one out
all right and at number 11 we've got rat
saw God from
Wednesday this was a late entry for me
this was an album I just listened to for
the first time as I was kind of catching
up on things here at the end of the year
but yeah this one's really special
Wednesday is a band from I think South
Carolina one of the Carolinas and
musically this reminds me a bit of I
would say snail mail maybe a little bit
bit of Frankie Cosmos but the
instrumentals are a bit heavier the
guitars are pretty distorted and pretty
loud but it works really well the
songwriting is excellent a lot of lyrics
on here that even on a first listen you
know caught me in my tracks and I was
really impressed with this one I can't
wait to hear more from Wednesday going
forward all right now we are in the top
10 and coming in at number 10 is
quaranta from Danny Brown if I knew you
I would send you to the St you might
remember that Danny Brown actually
announced this album I think for the
first time on the interview he did with
me which is really insane I can't
believe I'm saying that as just a fan of
this guy's music but this is obviously
the 10 years later followup to Triple X
as now he is past 40 years old and the
music reflects that greatly right this
is a lot more mature than I think we're
used to hearing from Danny and he's much
more in his head and in his emotions
than we're used to hearing and I think
he navigates it extremely well even amid
all the self-reflection there are still
some bangers in here too great features
especially to Bruiser wolf shout out to
him but yeah this this is a really solid
album and such a cool progression to see
in Danny's catalog next at number nine
from cautious clay I have carpet I need
another now cautious Clay is an artist I
was sort of familiar with I think I just
heard a a hit or two back a couple years
ago but I did not know that he was
making this kind of music This Album I'm
pretty sure I reviewed it and described
it as anthropological Jazz it is a very
Jazzy album and he's still got his R&B
chops too there's some songs where he
sings but yeah the entire album is kind
of exploring his lineage it's such a
unique listen there's just I can't think
of another album I've heard that's quite
like this one and yeah so much of it is
enjoyable I really love this one coming
in at number eight I've got haunted
Mountain from Buck
Meek saw if you don't know Buck Meek is
the lead guitarist from Big Thief I
believe I'm sure he contributes to the
songw writing there as well but I don't
know what it is why why are the Big
Thief artists so good when they do solo
work too I mean Adrian lanker is
incredible and this is my first time
listening to Buck Meek solo work and
this album is also really good much more
folky than Big Thief you know kind of
veering into country folk territory and
I feel like he just provides backup
vocals when he's in Big Thief but he can
really carry his own and that shows on
here I would never wish for the band to
break up but I would like more solo
projects from him and Adrien lanker at
number seven I've got let's start here
from Lil
yachty I don't think I've had a chance
to really talk about yachty on my
channel before and frankly I've never
really been a fan of him as a rapper I
just never got into his rap music like
that there have been a couple songs here
and there and I did like Poland from
last year but then this year he decides
to put out an album and it's not a rap
album at all he's kind of exploring
psych rock some R&B and funky stuff and
yeah it just this album really works
very well for me there's so much on here
that I do enjoy and it was just I mean
it was shocking at the beginning of the
year to get this from Lotti and it's
still shocking now to think that you
know this is my top 10 of the year and
it's from an artist that I've never
really been into I don't think that my
opinions of him as a rapper have changed
and I think he's I feel like he's been
saying a lot of outlandish stuff about
how great he is as a rapper which I
don't think is true but if he continues
down this road continues experimenting I
think he's got a lot of great music and
great musical ideas in him and this
album definitely showcases that well
coming in at number six I've got another
late entry for the Year this is the
greater wings from Julie burn I to be
this is an artist I had never heard of
before I think I saw this album somebody
listed it in their top albums or
something and yeah this one kind of blew
me away if you remember a couple years
ago I was really into that Cassandra
Jenkins album an overview on phenomenal
nature this one reminds me of that album
but it's more ethereal and it's even
more peaceful than that one this is a
very cool I don't even know what genre
this would be considered I think you
could make an argument that it's ambient
I think it's obviously got some folk
elements to it as well again I'm not a
genre expert but this one is definitely
definitely worth listen if you're in the
mood for something peaceful something
meditative this is this would be my
number one recommendation for the year
for sure and though as soon as I say
that we get to another meditative type
of album and this is uh at number five
burning desire from
[Music]
Mike Mike is a sort of underground
experimental kind of rapper in a similar
vein is guys like Billy Woods and Earl
sweatshir at this point too and yeah
this is that kind of hip-hop that is
just really good to put you in a certain
head space a lot of short tracks very
hypnotic very relaxing cool samples all
over the place if you're a fan of that
kind of hip-hop another big example
would be like I said Earl Sweatshirt his
some rap songs but yeah if you're into
that kind of he woozy hip-hop that's
going to maybe put you in some kind of
Trance State I really really love this
one and shout out to this too this is my
album cover of the Year all right coming
in at number four I've got the record
from boy Genius
IM I'm a big fan of Phoebe Bridges and
when boy Genius released their I don't
know if it was quite an album a couple
years ago I really liked that one too
and in the aftermath of that album and
going forward I've become a fan of Lucy
dasis as well and Julian Baker so
another boy Genius project really hits
the spot for me as usual these three are
exceptional songwriters and they work
really well together I think you'd be
hard pressed to find this kind of
chemistry from any just three singer
songwriters that are out there and their
friendship really shines through in a
lot of these songs not much more I can
say about this one but I'm also really
excited to see that they got nominated
for Grammy I am rooting for them and
hype aside the album is great I really
love this one all right this one is
going to cause some controversy but my
number three album of the year is for
all the dogs from Drake
No now I can already hear the the
collective groans coming from my
audience so I feel like I owe you guys
an explanation and I'm going to give
that to you it's no secret that I have
been critical of Drake in the past but
I've also been a fan of Drake if you've
seen I did a long video about honestly
never mind and I kind of went into this
there a couple years ago now he put out
CB and I don't even want to say the full
title CU it's embarrassing but my review
of that was that he was like a Pokemon
holding an Everstone and that he refused
to evolve I don't want to be so bold or
presumptuous as to say that Drake saw my
review but I feel like everything that
he has released since that album has
been in one way or another compelling to
me honestly never mind I really enjoyed
her loss had a lot of great songs too
and then for all the dogs this is maybe
my favorite Drake album since views the
other elephant in the room that I have
to address with this album is that Drake
is one of only two artists in existence
where I have edited albums from them the
other of course is Kanye West and with
Kanye when he releases albums that are
un finished and kind of Demand work I
was willing to work on those I did it
with life of Pablo and I did it with
dond those are the only two with Drake
it's a little different starting with
views cuz views is an album I really
loved but views was too long to fit on a
CD and I wanted to put it on a CD so I
had to edit it for time there's no way
around that when I'm trying to put it on
a CD I have to edit it and
coincidentally pretty much every album
after views I just didn't like that much
so rather than editing the albums I
would just pull out the songs that I
liked which was usually just a handful
maybe three four or five you know little
EPS where it post clb honestly never
mind I like the whole album her loss I
liked about half of it which I think was
eight songs and then here this one for
all the dogs it is empirically too long
it is once again too long to fit on a CD
so if I want to do that I have to edit
for time I did make a playlist that's up
on Apple music and Spotify that is sort
of my version of the album but I want to
be clear I didn't really edit this in
the same way that I did with those Kanye
projects because I don't touch the
sequencing or anything I just kind of
cut out the songs that I would otherwise
skip or don't really want to listen to
my version of for all the dogs if you
will I want to say is 16 tracks so I cut
out maybe seven there's only a couple
early on that I don't like I think the
21 Savage song isn't good and then after
8: a.m. in Charlotte I just cut the rest
of the album and it's not like those
songs are all bad it's just that I think
8: a.m. and Charlotte is such a strong
finish for this album so just cutting
out those handful of songs it's 55
minutes and it's still those 55 minutes
all those songs I really really enjoy
and I know that there are going to be
people saying how can you rate an album
that you did some work on or that you
edited in some way as one of your
favorites of the Year well I went back
and listened to the album with the songs
that I excluded and I think I would
still put it in my top 10 it might be a
little lower if I had to include those
but the other reality is that I've
listened to this one more than just
about everything else that I've talked
about so far I just really really like
what he's given us on this one I feel
like this album showcases a lot of his
best talents there are some great
singing songs on here and there's some
great rapping songs and then when he
released that Deluxe with more songs
those were again those were truly some
of the best rap songs he's ever made I'm
genuinely shocked because I don't I
can't think of the last time I would
have had a Drake album this high in a
year- end list I I wouldn't say that
it's as good as an album like views or
as good as Nothing Was the Same but it's
truly next in line I think after those
two and maybe take care as well and then
yeah he releases a deluxe which is just
six more tracks and it's six of the best
rap songs he's ever made and I don't
even think I can tack those on to the
end of this album because then I would
again have to edit for time Drake
definitely has a problem when it comes
to making albums that are too long this
is only the second Drake album where I
would say that I love it minus a few
songs and I don't think the fact that I
would skip those songs diminishes my
enjoyment but yeah whether I listen to
the entire album and not pay attention
to or skip the songs that I don't like
or if I listen to 55 minutes or 16 of
the 20 3 songs and really love it front
to back yeah this is one of my favorites
of the Year all right and now we are in
top two territory and my number two
album of the year is Lana Del re did you
know that there's a tunnel under Ocean
Boulevard I've been a fan of Lana since
born to die and I still really love that
album for years and years I would have
said that Born to Die is your best album
This is the first one to change that for
me and it's really cool to see how far
she's come in a little over 10 years
it's kind of like seeing the progression
of Danny Brown from Tri XX to corant
we've got Lana Del re going from Born to
Die to this this is another one produced
by Jack Antonoff and I feel like she
does an excellent job on that kind of
production and they work really well
together these songs have sort of an air
and Mystique to them that just it hits
like nothing else that I've heard from
her and it's a long album but it is
worth the experience from front to back
because there's just so much life
stuffed into this one I'm pretty sure
she's nominated for a bunch of Grammys
and I would love to see see her win
those just because this album really is
that special this is going to be this
will probably end up in my favorites of
the decade and yeah it'll it'll be
interesting to see if and when she can
put out something that I enjoy more than
this one but I think I would have said
that about Born to Die for the last 10
years so I'm looking forward to see what
it might happen next if you haven't
listened to this one please do yourself
a favor check it out and now my number
one album of the year which might not
come as a surprise to anybody it is
scaring the hose from jpeg Mafia and
Danny Brown
obviously I'm a fan of both J Peg Mafia
and Denny Brown and the combination of
those two it's hard to say I wouldn't
have predicted it'd be this good because
I know that they're both exceptionally
talented but Danny Brown sounds perfect
on jpeg Mafia production and he and jpeg
go back and forth on all these songs and
it just sounds really excellent really
energized this is maybe one of the
wildest first listens that I had all
year and this is also probably my most
listened album for the entire year I
threw this thing on front to back all
the time I just think the production is
so interesting and both of these guys
are interesting rappers and vocalists
and to hear them go back and forth on
music this exciting and this strange it
just makes for a really great experience
they're obviously pushing boundaries and
trying different genres and sub genres
and a lot of that I guess you could
credit jpeg Mafia on the production but
Danny really brings the heat too with
his rapping and even singing on some of
the songs like Orange Juice Jones is one
of my favorites and Danny singing on
that one is just awesome there's
obviously been a lot of great music this
year but nothing that I have come back
to as consistently and as aggressively
as this album and album of the Year
absolutely deserved for these guys and
as a final note I think this was called
scaring the host volume one so if
they've got more music I know they put
out an EP this year as well but if
they've got another album's worth of
this or if they want to keep working
together please I will take whatever I
can get from this also I should have
addressed this at the beginning of of
this video but I'm just coming off a
cold so if I look or sound a little out
of it that would be why but anyway those
are albums of the year and now going on
to my favorite tracks or songs of the
year every year I do a playlist of 100
songs I'm going to link a YouTube
version with this video as well as links
to that on Spotify and apple music I'll
just give you a sampling here I'll give
you just a taste of what to expect from
that
playlist
like I told her my name is simp she said
no don't want on your birth
[Applause]
certificate baby set tell the preach
never finish that's to say the
least waying heavy on my moral scale
knowing they going to sell another
citizen
[Music]
Kaner maybe they wanted to be a boxer
until they found out that they couldn't
fight I just had a dream I
was I was all right and to wrap things
up for those who chose to stick around
let me go over my favorite movies shows
and some video games this year so my top
10 movies of the year starting at number
10 I've got past lives infinity pool the
Creator Barbie
ironclaw number five the boy in the
herin number four asteroid City number
three killers of the flower Moon number
two Heimer and number one poor things
hey guys editor version of Ruff criminal
here in the time that's passed since I
recorded this video I watched Bo is
afraid from Ari Aster and that's a
fantastic movie I'm going to have to
insert that one here at probably number
three so everything else would shift
down one I don't watch a lot of TV shows
but here's what I've really enjoyed this
year the curse from Nathan Fielder
blueeyed Samurai which is a Netflix
anime beef which is another Netflix show
Min series I think jury duty was great
and I still have to watch the new
seasons of invincible I'm waiting till
the full thing comes out to watch that
second season and then I'm about halfway
through the new season of the bear I
really love that show too and lastly
video games which is honestly what I
spend a lot of my time doing Starfield
was a big one it's not a perfect game
but I really enjoyed that and I love
exploring space so I've been having a
lot of fun with that one it's been a big
year for me on fortnite we had an OG
season which was fun and then they just
introduced a Lego fortnite mode they've
got a music festival mode which is
basically Guitar Hero and then the
racing mode which is sort of a crossover
with rocket League there's a lot going
on in fortnite now but I feel like
they've stuck the landing on it pretty
well excited to see how all this stuff
pans out and then lastly you might be
aware that the big game of the year was
balers Gate 3 and I got into that one
pretty recently I'm an Xbox player and
that just got ported to Xbox actually
the night that they won game of the year
so I've been playing that a lot since
then and I really love that I as
somebody who has played Dungeons and
Dragons It's a fantastic video game
version of that can't wait to syn
hundreds of hours into that game too so
yeah that's 2023 for you uh thank you
guys for sticking around with my channel
I've obviously not been very consistent
this past year like I said in other
videos I moved just have a lot going on
in my life but you know what when I have
things to talk about when I've got
things to share with you guys I want to
do that I don't want to make any
promises I can't keep but I want to come
through with some more 10-second reviews
and keep the momentum going a little bit
next year and then I've got a cap off
my favorite albums of the 2010s list so
look forward to that this year and then
yeah we we'll try to keep the ball
rolling where we can where inspiration
strikes me thank you guys I hope you had
a great holiday season and here's to